what do you perform more uh the BBC or
uh Mr uh husband over here because
that's why you put us in two different
rooms
exactly we could just be truthful here
guys truthful okay
um I did enjoy uh Jason's new everything
not new is interesting and fun but
uh what you made him leave look at that
I'm sorry I'm just trying to catch a
breath so wait did you choose Jason over
your husband when they ask you that
question
lie I'm sorry why okay it's like when
they ask the men they'll ask the men is
your wife the most beautiful woman in
the world you know damn well that she is
not the most beautiful woman in the
world but the men lie to us all the time
it's like you can't just lie a little
bit in public and just say no I
preferred my husband it wasn't that
great